fantastic all right 609 on your Monday
morning what's driving you crazy well if
you thought the lane restrictions on the
desert and super arterial were a thing
of the past you need to think again the
Nevada Department of Transportation says
there's going to be shifting lane
closures both directions of di between
Valley View and Paradise starting at
nine tonight scheduled to run until
seven the next morning until Thursday
now restricting those restrictions to
those hours means that the cones and
flashing lights shouldn't be too hard to
deal with except for when they run into
the morning rush hour when you could be
late to wherever you're going indot says
it's all for another round of repaving
di now maybe you want to skip the whole
thing maybe write yourself a sticky note
and use Spring Mountain Sands or Twain
or Sahara for your overnight early
morning East-West travel this week
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone you can join the driving
you crazy conversation at traffic eight
at eightnewsnow.com